you les paras potes c'est cyrus j'espère
que vous allez bien voilà je prends un
petit moment pour sortir de paris
apprécié une petite marche en forêt ça
fait depuis septembre je crois que suis
pas sortie de paris donc ça me fait du
bien
aujourd'hui je vous parlais de
l'algorithme et youtube alors j'ai pas l
algorithme sur genre les grosses vidéos
qui va mettre en avant qui va propulser
en tendance apparaît donc la
monétisation de plus vous parler d'un
sujet qui me touche beaucoup
c'est le sujet du complotisme en fait le
truc c'est que il ya un moment il ya
beaucoup de gens qui disaient que le
problème c'est qu'on commence par
regarder une vidéo mainstream et de fil
en aiguille on se fait guider par
l'algorithme et on tombe sur des vidéos
complotistes c'est quelque chose que
j'ai beaucoup entendu mais je n'ai
jamais personnellement expérimenté et
donc j'étais curieux de le faire donc je
suis dit que ce qui pouvait être
intéressant de faire c'est un live de 24
heures où pendant 24 heures je me laisse
guider dans la refondation sans toucher
quoi que ce soit l'idée c'est de voir si
même sans intervention humaine
est-ce que youtube d'une certaine
manière est biaisé est-ce que youtube de
lui même va m'emmener vers sa vidéo
composite
donc je vous montrais cette expérience
et un live que j'ai tourné il ya
plusieurs mois j'étais dans mon ancien
appart
c'est un live de 24 heures qui a été
condensées en quelques minutes et après
ce live on va trouver quelqu'un qui
travaille sur l'algorithme chez youtube
c'est parti pour l'expérience nous voici
dans la partie intime expérience j'ai
écrit un compte youtube de toutes pièces
qui n'existe pas
j'ai vidé tous mes coups qui est ce que
je vais mettre en x 2 je veux pas l'être
en x 2 parce que j'ai pas envie que ça
joue dans la lgo tu vas d'une manière ou
d'une autre
alors évidemment on va pas
passer notre temps à regarder toutes les
vidéos donc je vais les mettre dans un
coin de l'image et moi pensent à faire
des jeux j'ai discuté avec des gens
voilà on va faire plein de trucs de
différentes façons là on est là ensemble
pour un bon bout de temps
puisqu'on est là pour 24 heures et c'est
parti c'est parti je vais vous montrer a
du coup l'écran d'accueil
j'ai peur si je pars sur un truc qui est
spécifique comme genre le sport je reste
dans du sport a dû signer alors que si
je vais sur un truc qui est beaucoup
plus larges comme du divertissement
je me dis ah peut-être plus de chances
qu'on compte des rives donc je vais
cliquez là dessus eh ben on est parti je
lance donc on est parti des tendances
pour pas faire de recherche pour pas
donner plus d'infos on a pris une vidéo
du plus gros youtuber de france squeeze
on a pris sa toute dernière vidéo on l'a
mis en grand écran on a laissé le son de
la vidéo mais on l'a coupé moi j'ai pris
son ordinateur pour pas entendre le son
du tube pendant 24 heures et voilà c'est
l'expérience est lancé on va voir petit
à petit ou est-ce que ça va nous emmener
et enfin le checkpoint ouais mon bon
charles tu es en haut parleurs je suis
sûr en live voilà c'est charleville à
charleville a le grand reporter et on
passe au cabillaud d'un salut à tous si
vous connaissez pas ce jeu on va jouer à
quito qing novi explode g lambda quoi
lambda le symbole de half life
ah ouais ok je pense que je les ok j'ai
ensuite un la moitié d'un air la moitié
droite ya un air hockey et après je suis
vraiment un cul oui et coupe le
quatrième fils il ya c'est bon tu
devrais faire une chaîne youtube de ça
tu la perds et le couple file au pas mal
[ __ ] et aux 14 parties [ __ ] on
repasse sur ducret guillotin deuxième
épisode mais c'est pas mon mot à elle
voté le même chiffre qu'elle a trois
donc c'est 4 yes
domino s est il qu'on aille avec ses
chants mais c'était de la balle mais je
encore sur un truc de grèzes guillotin
c'est fou dans max et des vidéos d'une
heure donc une fois que tu le regardes
et là je suis parti sur quarante minutes
degré guillotin quoi gros bisous bisous
art très bonne question de hnz tu penses
que la lgo va te re proposer des vidéos
que ceux déjà vu au bout d'un moment
c'est une question qui s'est posée aussi
sur twitter quand j'ai parlé de ce
challenge et de cette expérience en vrai
jespere pas j'espère pas parce que ce
serait un peu bête
d'une certaine manière de la part de
l'algorithme puisque son but c'est que
je reste le plus longtemps possible sur
la plateforme donc s'ils meurent propose
des vidéos a priori bah je vais quitter
quoi donc si ils nous le propose
on verra ce qu'on fait ensemble et on
verra quelle décision qu'on prend à yugo
des crips de french youtube mc ensuite
sur l'âge c'est pas con 20e vidéos de
vacances arrivent nous paul gray
guillotin c'est la merde
mais non je me tape encore greg
guillotin gros cette pub et ypres allons
quoi c'est quoi ce truc de six minutes
de lidl découverte de la sienne anglais
avait des gars s'ils font pas des pubs
en fait ils font des vidéos
ça c'est le truc que j'aurais appris je
crois mais du coup on est tous là en
train de se battre en mid et toi tu es
là ces normes techniques et est allée
des ventes repartiront quoi il aurait
fallu que j'en butin sous qu'ils étaient
cinq
mais non mais sauf qu'on était là gros
et là tu dois partir d'un sérieux ouais
une centaine d'années c'était quoi cet
art en attente est bon il faut aller tig
et ils viennent mais non au talon gauche
yes yes dj guys assez gros bisous
l'habitat merci zizou
[Musique]
bon on semble être tombé dans un look
d'algorithmes j'avoue je pensais pas que
la déco il fallait nous re proposer des
vidéos qu'on a déjà vu c'est cache pas
que c'est un peu décevant parce que je
prends pas la logique je me dis que si
l'algorithme son but est que je reste le
plus longtemps possible mais pas me
reprocher de les mêmes choses donc là ça
fait 7 heures qu'on est en live on a
commencé par donc une vidéo de squeeze
et depuis c'est que du gris guillotin et
en plus cette vidéo qui font des heures
enfin qui font du 50 minutes et c'est
donc à priori voilà on a pas dériver
vers des trucs qui pouvait être j'ai pas
potentiellement complotistes défectueux
ou ce genre de choses on est vraiment
resté sur du divertissement du coup est
ce que ça vaut le coup de continuer je
suis pas sûr je suis pas sûr parce que
si on est dans une boucle
je nous vois mal nous en sortir donc
est-ce que c'est pas le moment d'essayer
d'être une autre vidéo de départ à
l'espace un très intéressant
en fait
dans sa story à 8h squeeze il a fait un
swipe up vers une vidéo de la guillotine
donc ça explique peut-être pourquoi
après la vidéo de squeeze on est tombé
sur nagui l'otan en même temps tu vois
genre nous a pas recommander celle que
lui il a recommandé nous aura commandé
la toute dernière vidéo de greg est un
qui est passé en tendance deere ok donc
là comme vous l'avez vu on est tombé
dans un loup paul de greg guillotin
c'est à dire une boucle de lucas
guillotin et gens qui meurent proposer
les mêmes vidéos de gaguie iota dans le
même ordre
non je suis que ça servait à rien de
continuer on a juste recevoir du grès
guillotin donc on est passé à
l'expérience de l'expérience 2 c'est que
je me suis dit qu'au lieu de partir
d'une vidéo hyper mainstream on va taper
carrément un truc qui peut amener au
complot sur la barre de recherche qu'on
a tapé 11 septembre
en tapant 11 septembre on a pris une
vidéo vraiment d'informations c'est une
vidéo de la fp qui était assez courte et
on se dit à partir de là est ce qu'on va
dériver vers du truc qui peut être
potentiellement complotistes sur le 11
septembre
c'est parti the board wri bon on va
partir sur un jeu vidéo vidéo c'est à
guillotin le pire stage achète attendait
qu'est-ce qui nous proposera ce qu'ils
nous proposent pas curiosité après
revivez les 72 minutes de radio canada
c'était le deuxième vient ça vient je
revois les images l'a fait c'est
terrible quand même cet attentat il est
terrible c'est ouf par contre je suis
assez surpris qu'on soit sur une vie à
une vidéo sur les navettes spatiales
j'ai hâte de voir la suite là je pense
qu'on va rester sur l'espace en fait on
a fait 11 septembre
hiroshima les différents types de bombes
les navettes spatiales ouais tu vois là
c'est armstrong un documentaire sur son
gain
50ème anniversaire de la nasa 27
donc ils nous ont vite sortis de tout ce
qui est polémique halal satan quoi
s'attend hugo tu sais que si je me mets
en valeur est là tout le monde va partir
moi je comme je réchauffe est comment
dire non à valoriser hugo weaving vont
bien aller
coubisou mon vieux mise au deuxième but
ou non mais là les gamins c'est
n'importe quoi la vidéo youtube sur
lesquels il est 3h du mat
on est sur une retransmission live de
apollo 11 ces retransmissions du live et
nos gars le chat mais attendez là je ne
sais pas quoi faire la passe que la
vidéo et lire 3h16 au mail a jugé le
sommes parce qu'en fait il va se passer
exactement même chose que greg guillotin
tu vois donc là de nouveau on arrêter
l'expérience parce que on allait perdre
beaucoup de temps sur des vidéos soient
en rapport avec l'espace donc on était
loin du sujet du 11 septembre et j'avais
peur qu'on retourne dans un loup paul et
c'est donc vrai je voulais pas qu'on
perde du temps donc autant passer à une
expérience 3 quand ap 11 septembre sur
la page y avait une vidéo qui parlait de
complot mais parler de complot pour les
démones qui était une vidéo de france
culture l'expérience 3c de cliquer sur
cette vidéo le tard tchad une vidéo
d'information pure on part sur une vidéo
2d bonne cage pouvoir si après on à
l'autre pan c'est à dire qu'on nous
parle de complot et ça a donné ça on va
partir de ça et c'est parti je passais
un créatif et les parterres mais s'ils
étaient porteurs de faire un petit un
squat rim toi et on discute parce qu'il
a parlé de youtube mois souvent j'ai ce
truc de caen je m'endors star avant de
relater youtube ça que je me réveille et
souvent je tombe je me rêvais toujours
sur après de très longs formats
je vais donc me cubaine en recréant
perdre est de plus en plus long c'est
exactement ça sert que d'une
recommandation à l'autre aja voilà du
réel
les triples ou quadruples enfin tuera
genre pour ce 4 prochaine on se parle
avec grand plaisir
sylla et son beauf alors sa géographie
ça marche vas-y gros bisous désolé je
suis éclaté ça l'a relégué évidemment
mon gendre avait heureusement je regarde
toujours sur l'hymne à quoi bon les amis
petit point il est désormais 10h30 du
matin sans nouveau enlisé dans un type
de vidéos cd vidéos de l'ina et cd
vidéos de tout le monde en parle de
l'ina voilà donc une niche un gars dix
ans donc pour rappel voilà ce qui s'est
passé si je remonte à tout le monde en
parle avec françois berléand jamel
debbouze julien lepers
ensuite il eric laurent la face cachée
du 11 septembre
en fait c'était un mec qui a écrit un
livre qui était sur le plateau de tout
le monde en parle
archives de l'ina là c'est un peu border
en vrai parce que c'est un mec qui est
complotistes et qui défend du coup son
propos sur le bateau teh on nous a quand
même mis ça après le france culture y at
il un complot derrière le 11-septembre
donc c'est intéressant de voir que mon
évidemment l'intention de france culture
n'était pas mauvaise en voulant parler
de complot sauf que du coup ça s'est
retrouvé dans la première page de
recherche sur le 11 septembre
et du coup la vidéo juste après que nous
était proposé c'est quand même un
complotiste sur un plateau télé que
c'est pas une vidéo complotistes et il
ya des gens qui peuvent le contredire
sur le plateau télé etc
mais ça reste un complotiste qui
s'exprime et donc qui donne sa vision
des faits etc
après une vidéo qui est censé débloquer
les choses et si ça sert en fait de
l'algo s'est dit ok en fait tu aimes les
émission d'ardisson chez dans les
archives ina ok on va te filer sa part
il a servi six heures deux ans je
voulais pas m'arrêter là donc je suis
allé encore plus loin dans l'expérience
nous a vus à chaque fois on se rapproche
dans les points de départ on se
rapproche du complot voilà je suis
carrément aller regarder un reportage un
documentaire compatissent 3 je pense
d'ailleurs que le mot documentaire n'est
pas vraiment approprié
on s'est dit qu'on allait regarder le
sucre et des pyramides parce que c'est
quand même assez long donc ça causait
une grosse information à la lgo et ça a
donné ça et pour pas être faussés par
résultats je vais prendre le lien
directement cette fois de la vidéo sans
recherche
on est parti tac
tac way sur de 4,9 millions de vues je
vais passer tout de suite à une sorte de
jeu on n'est pas trop d'image de ce truc
nauséabond je peux me permettre
paris de place en place émissions
intégrales des racines et des ailes
c'est intéressant là c'est intéressant
qui nous est sortie directe alors
maintenant on va le challenge est un bel
album je suis pas satisfait de ça je
passe et si la voiture est très
compétitif thaïlande la route des rois
ok donc on va sur en fait c'est en effet
ce documentaire géographique pour
l'instant il n'a pas du tout pris en
compte le coût des complotistes des
pyramides
je passe ça m'intéresse pas norvège sur
la route des fjords je pars patagonie
indonésie ah non c'est fini a pas de
donc on voit que la lgo à n'a pas retenu
ce truc de complotisme et les plus
rester dans les documentaires voyage
donc a priori cette phrase que j'ai
entendu sur les complots bas elle est
fausse en tout cas ce qui a été vrai un
moment mais les plus maintenant mais moi
ce qui m'intéresse aussi
c'est d'avoir le point de vue de youtube
sur tout ça parce que c'est cool de
faire ça dans son coin etc
mais quand on a quelqu'un qui a
potentiellement travailler sur
l'algorithme et qui nous donne son point
de vue là c'est intéressant
donc j'ai créé à youtube et m'ont
répondu favorablement j'ai pas encore
fait l'interview par rapport aux houches
tourner cette vidéo elle et demain matin
donc je sais pas encore ce que ça va
donner mais a priori ça donne ça merci à
vincent d'avoir accepté ma demande pour
qu'on puisse se parler un petit peu donc
toi c'est quoi ton rôle par rapport à la
lgo déjà merci beaucoup pour ton
invitation c'est un grand plaisir pour
moi de pouvoir échanger aujourd'hui et
donc moi parce que je travaille pour des
tubes fait partie des équipes
d'ingénierie de youtube à paris en
france on a une équipe potager dire
qu'ils travaillent fait partie de la
médiation qui travaillent sur cliquez
sur fond de disco bd d'algorithmes qui
permettent pas plus utilisateurs de
trouver les vidéos qui est utilisateur
sur la plateforme ont travaillé dur pour
les améliorer continuer d'être pu voir
le live de 24 heures l'expérience avec
les différentes expériences sous gestion
de poser cette question parce que parler
des recommandations c'est vraiment au
coeur de l'expérience de toutes nos
utilisateurs nous c'est vraiment à
quelque chose d'essentiel pour la
plateforme pour l'utilisateur
le premier point sur lequel que la
première vie d'expérience à sur partir
d'autant une question incognito à partir
d'une vidéo sera cédée de squeeze soit 4
tu pars là je pense que ce que tu
observes sur cette séquence là c'est un
petit peu lié à la manière dont
l'expérience des fêtes et d'occuper une
cession gas aucun qui a rien et tu
laisses ça
l'algorithme faire des recommandations
les unes après les autres sans
intervenir parce qu'en fait qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que l'algorithme qui
cherche à faire c'est à comprendre les
intérêts des utilisateurs à partir de
son historique de visionnage pour faire
des relations qui sont le plus à même de
satisfaire l'utilisateur est donc là
encore une question il n'y a pas
d'information d'aiguillon connais pas
utilisateurs et on laisse les
recommandations à avancer tout seul
naturellement la seule information que
l'algorithme après que les quelques
premières vidéos c'était des
vidéocaméras soutien parce que tu restes
trois heures a ajouté que la guillotine
en confirmant déduit d'une enquête
intéressé par perec guillotin ça sur
l'information condamne donc c'est assez
logique on rentre dans une série de
recommandations qui en quelque part se
ressemble à un petit peu alors que dans
une session un peu plus réaliste en fait
à chaque étape
l'utilisateur peut sélectionner une
autre recommandation à chaque fois on va
avoir un peu d'informations être cet
isolat lui a plu ou pas est ce qui la
regarde monde entier ou est-ce qu'il a
switché après dix secondes parce que
c'était patine truc c'est une chance que
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'autres
observent ce mécanisme mais ce qui était
bizarre c'est que l'on retombé sur genre
exactement les mêmes vidéos
ouais ça j'ai trouvé faire intéressant à
est d'ailleurs sur power la séquence ça
m'intéresserait de garde et de débusquer
parce qu'en général on faire ça et vite
évidemment danser dans ces séquences la
queue on retombe sur la même vidéo a
donc je sais pas ce qu'il s'est passé là
peut-être que c'est bien parce qu'elle
est très longue vidéo où des choses de
sica mais ça serait intéressant en
général entre d'avoir des vies nos
différentes effectivement il ya aussi un
an qui était intéressant dans un petit
mois m'intéresse dans cette expérience
c'est l'angle complotistes un petit peu
est-ce que vous il ya un moment où ça a
été un challenge faire en sorte que la
lgo ne recommande pas des vidéos
complotistes ou est-ce que ça n'a jamais
été un sujet alors ça c'est ce qu'on m'a
beaucoup travailler comme je le disais à
notre but c'est de
de maximiser la satisfaction et
l'engagement de nos utilisateurs sur la
plateforme mais a au dessus de ça on
souhaite aussi assurer notre
responsabilité vis-à-vis de la société
et on pense qu'il ya un certain nombre
de recommandations de vidéos qu'on ne
souhaite pas recommandée proactivement
la plateforme elles peuvent être créés
dans sa plate forme puisque et la
liberté d'expression et on pense que
c'est important que cette liberté
d'expression soit respectée mais on
pense aussi que c'est notre
responsabilité de ne pas encourager la
recommandation de ses vidéos donc on a
énormément travaillé à depuis 2010 9 /
améliorer une recommandation pour
assurer notre responsabilité et en
particulier limiter l'exposition du
contenu qui est fait par un peu limite
par rapport aux règles de la plateforme
est aujourd'hui moins de 1 % du temps
d'écouter la plate forme est sûre sur ce
contenu là donc on a fait un énorme
travail pour réduire l'exposition de nos
sénateurs à second c'est là c'est un
algo qui comprend que c'est cetc des
faits qui nous ou ce genre de choses où
c'est qu'on sent donc sa combinaison de
deux du travail de deux personnes qui
visionne le contenu et qu'il analyse et
un algorithme qui permet de faire ça à
l'échelle parce que chaque jour on a
plus de soixante douze années de contenu
qui ait meilleure mine soit plate forme
évidemment pas toujours gardé mais on a
vraiment la combinaison de travail de
personne qui regarde le contenu est
ensuite un algorithme qui permettent de
détente a tous les atouts pour lui donc
potentiellement si j'avais fait la même
expérience par mois y as il ya trois ans
j'aurais eu des résultats différents
notamment sur la dernière où je commence
vraiment par les pyramides là le secret
des pyramides présents certains domaines
d'organes on a énormément travaillé et
on continue à travailler dessus ont
retenu à améliorer notre travail
j'ai remarqué un truc aussi c'est que
j'ai besoin que vous privilégiez plus
alors est ce que c'est vrai est ce que
c'est juste dans cette expérience est ce
que voilà mais en dessous que l'émetteur
est plus privilégiés que le contenu en
lui-même c'est que l'ina on a regardé
une vidéo où il y avait un complotiste
sur le plateau pourtant à pont à
proposer que de lilas mais rien à voir
et que l'on s'attende quoi de manière
générale le créateur de la vidéo n'est
pas
la caractéristique principale qui va
guider les recommandations la
caractéristique principale c'est qu'est
ce que les utilisateurs qui regardent
des vidéos similaires on regarde alors
évidemment en général chaque utilisateur
à ses créateurs favoris donc évidemment
assez souvent des associations fait au
niveau d'études des créateurs mais c'est
pas fondamentalement le critère qui
l'utilisé fondamentalement c'est
qu'est-ce que les les gens qui ont
regardé les mêmes vidéos ont apprécié
sur l'abattoir et donc je peux imaginer
dans lequel à des vidéos de l'ina mais
c'est juste qu'on a pas mal
d'utilisateurs qui regardent des dt
suite de vidéos des archives de l'ina
sur différents sujets dont la fac sacré
c'est ses connexions entre les entrées
vidéo parce que du coup la vidéo avec le
complotisme la chaire disent on est ce
que maintenant vous allez à fly et comme
composer son talent mais elle est très
je pense donc déjà ce n'était pas mon
travail personnellement de claquer les
vidéos et je pense que c'est important
c'est à dire qu'on a des processus qui
sont bien définis avec des règles qui
sont qui sont ou qui sont bien définis
pour identifier ces vidéos là donc là
elle peut être regarder à nouveau par
quelqu'un en charge de cette
classification là qui a toutes les
connaissances précises je pense que
c'est un exemple intéressant puisqu'il
est vraiment on à côté ça passe
évidemment rester quelqu'un qui soutient
une théorie complotiste sur sur les
événements mais autre côté c'est une
interview qui était dans un cadre légal
ouais ça bien défini une émission de
télévision etc pour faire la part des
choses entre les différentes
manipulations
si jamais quelqu'un voulait la tags etc
il ya eu 10 le bouton signaler j'imagine
bien continuer sa plateforme qui permet
de sept heures de signaler les vidéos et
ses vidéos approvisionnés par par nos
équipes pour comprendre les mesures qui
sont qui sont appropriés donc tu vois la
mairie merci beaucoup
franchement merci beaucoup pour ton
temps la rochelle pas de circulation
sont utiles et l aideront à continuer à
s' est super intéressant mais déjà rien
que d'entendre entre guillemets youtube
là dessus c'est trop bien parce qu'un
vrai il ya un dialogue entre nous et la
plateforme nous soit les créateurs ou
les viewers hélas platement
c'est super utile parce que c'est aussi
le dialogue qui doublerait
continuellement d'améliorer la
plateforme mais il ya beaucoup du
feedback qu'on reçoit des créateurs qui
nous sont qui traduit directement dans
des améliorations et dans des évolutions
de la torre super content merci j'espère
que cette vidéo vous a plu or pour moi
et pourquoi elle est particulière parce
que elle se fait vraiment s'est étalée
sur le temps d'une manière non prévue
par rapport à maintenant il ya des bouts
de la vidéo que j'ai tourné vachement
dans le passé il ya des bouts de la
vidéo que je devrais dans le futur en
bref c'est assez marrant mais ça m'a
donné envie de faire une autre vidéo sur
le sujet avec un autre live
potentiellement de 24 heures ou de cette
fois je mets la dimension humaine
donc en gros on a vu que l'algorithme
nous guider pas tout seul vers du
complot mais si je voulais aller vers le
complot en combien de temps je peux y
aller ça c'est une question que je me
pose en tout cas j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a plu voilà c'était je me
souviens le live de 24 heures c'était
assez intense ceux qui étaient là pas en
live et qui voit cette vidéo bassano
faire aussi bizarre nou lé pa je suis
sur twitter tous les mardis je voulais
plus d'informations en descriptions et
si vous voulez être au courant du
prochain live 24 heures que je vais
faire je vais en parler sûrement sur
instagram et twitter ce n'est remercie
aussi youtube qui a été vachement cool
de me laisser faire cette interview
merci pour votre confiance et on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour une
nouvelle vidéo love peace ciao
[Musique]